alle jahre wieder macht die bayerische
gemeinde holzkirchen ihren bedürftigen
mitbürgern zum fest ein kleines
weihnachtsgeschenk 30 euro extra aus der
gemeindekasse
so ist es hier seit jahrzehnten
tradition aber daraus wird dieses jahr
nix der grund der datenschutz
bürgermeister olaf von löwis ist ratlos
er weiß nicht wie man das geld geben
soll
die namen und adressen konnten uns
dieses jahr nicht gegeben werden von der
entsprechenden stelle im landratsamt
weil es sich um hoch sensible
personenbezogene daten handelt und die
datenschutz situation recht einfach
verbietet dass diese daten an uns
weitergegeben werden
jahrzehntelang war alles kein problem
immer bekam die gemeinde die namen der
berechtigten vom landratsamt miesbach zu
gesamt damit war klar wer sich die 30
euro im rathaus abholen konnte in diesem
jahr aber weigert sich der kreis weil er
in der weitergabe der namen plötzlich
einen verstoß gegen die datenschutz
grund verordnung sieht in holzkirchen
können die bürger nicht fassen dass es
illegal sein soll eine liste vom
kreishaus zum rathaus zu schicken
dieses problem ist typische deutsche
kleinkarierte korinthenkacker heftigkeit
par excellence schlimmer geht es glaube
ich gar nicht wenn der gemeinde mal
wirklich warst du dann immer einfach
neuer bisher boards zu die leiden macht
und den elektra dann einfach per gesetz
irgendwelche dinge in den weg finde ich
sehr traurig dass mit den neuen
datenschutz
dieser wahnsinn und das sonst eigentlich
ballaballa im landratsamt weist man jede
verantwortung fürs geschenke desaster
weit von sich schriftlich heißt es man
halte sich streng an recht und gesetz
es gelte die dsgv unmittelbar in allen
eu mitgliedstaaten also auch der
bundesrepublik deutschland den
mitgliedstaaten der eu ist das
grundsätzlich nicht erlaubt den
festgeschriebenen datenschutz durch
nationale regelungen abzuschwächen für
die bürger in holzkirchen ist das ganze
schlicht ein weihnachtlicher bürokraten
ihr sinn
ich finde es ganz ehrlich unfassbar das
ist an uns oder datenschutz verordnung
ist ja auch darum seinen vorteilen
dieser rainer bürokratie ist ja dass
praktisch geld vom bürger was dem bürger
eigentlich wieder zurückgibt und da
macht man solche solche aktionen das ja
gesagt das finde ich schon gesagt
unmöglich
das fest wird bei den menschen die ihn
nicht viel haben noch ein bisschen
bescheidener ausfallen
zumindest einen hoffnungsschimmer gibt
es im neuen jahr will die gemeinde
weiter nach einem schlupfloch im
datenschutz suchen um das geld dann doch
noch auszuzahlen